[Music]
hi I'm Christopher hi and we're talking
more about basic book in work so it's
important when you understand but can
work what the attack types are and this
is a big discussion that we're having in
the in the world is you know or that has
been had for the last several hundred
years was what's better thrusts or
slashes or cuts which which one's better
and there's lots of things you need to
think about when you think about these
the truth is we need both of them and we
both of them for a bunch of different
reasons so we're going to talk a little
bit about those and we're gonna talk
about how those two ideas relate to come
I so if I could get Josh to come in here
with me okay
so if we're both here in your mind and I
need to launch an attack if I'm
launching a thrust I don't need any prep
interaction which means I can attack by
just entering in if I'm going to launch
some kind of thrust or chop or something
like that I'm gonna have to prepare the
action first and this means that he it's
a moment of time where he can do
something right so every time I set my
strike first Josh will be acting in that
moment so if he's right on it and I'm
raising my strike up he can enter into
that space and get me so that's an
important thing you have to understand
is that anytime you're launching a
clothing attack then you have to prepare
the action now one way I can kind of
work around that is if I go up into Joe
Don Kenya by so if I came up here
this now I've already prepped my action
so I'm already set up so when I get up
there if top started coming towards me
it's really easy for me to deliver
whatever strike it is that I'm gonna
deliver when I want to get this done so
by coming up into Joe Don come on I've
already prepped my attack now I don't
want to put my attack while I'm in range
so right now if job takes a step in you
can hit me right and with the trusty
nice to me every time with that but
imperfect okay so if I could go into Joe
Don Kenyan mind now and he's right on
the moment he's gonna get in there you
know understand this is not a bad shot
for him because if my my next action is
for my arms to go down and his next
actually is for his arms to go huh he'll
be able to complete himself as I'm
coming in so I couldn't give him a free
shot that way and I don't want to do
that so if I go into the Joe Don can
come on I want to step on brains right
so I know I'm safe then I can set that
range one nice thing to understand about
using Jonah and Kenny combined is when I
said it I can either go forward back or
stay in place with my command let me
show you what I mean so we're here I
just sent Jonah kids mine by going back
I could set Jonah can combine by going
forward and I can set Jonah Khimki mine
in place so that's easy if this guy's
really close to me and I want to go to
Jonah kidding mine I can make distance
while setting you're on can't mine but
what's really nice about this is if he
chooses to chase me when I do this but
yet the action is immediately right
there to come in and attack so Joe
continued my is setting up the cutting
action ahead of time so that way I don't
have to have a preparatory action right
so it's kind of a way to cheat that rule
that I talked about before if I'm going
in to get on Kenny my what's happening
is I'm removing my obvious defense
so what I feel like this I'm removing my
obvious defense which means to Josh I
look like I'm pretty much set up for
attack so yeah I was slight data rate
into my second gate on when we come into
range
if jobs are to attack me I can move to
the side this way you come in there's
lots of ways that can set up an attack
from gate on but basically what data
does is it draws them in so I came out
of range a little bit so that way you
couldn't attack me while I was dropping
my sword and then as I start to push
into that rank I'm set up for action
immediately I can also move it so it
gone generally a way to lure someone in
so you can get up keep in mind I want to
draw him in chudan confined space again
and he's someone that the distance gives
me maximum offense and defense
all in one joking things mind doesn't
give me a lot of defense but gives me
really powerful offense so understand
that's the basic way you're going to use
those now when we're talking about
what's better cuts or thrusts you have
to understand what is it you're trying
to do for example he had some kind of
really ferocious our neuron may be a
simple cuts not going to go through it
but a well delivered thrust could get
into the right spot right or it could be
that he's in some position that getting
in with the good thrust isn't good for
me into if I'm dealing with multiple
attackers then thrusts are generally a
bad way to go right so you know if we
had jobs here and there
they're not over there if I were to
attack them all with rust I'm going to
throw this over here reset runs over
here reset thrust over here it's a lot
more power might take a cut so I came a
little out of action or a little out of
range of this guy and is that my cut up
I've easily come in and swipe all those
guys in one shot right so depending on
what kind of situation I'm facing will
determine the kind of attack I want to
make the rusts aren't just naturally
better and cuts and slashes aren't
naturally better it just depends on the
situation and fittings like everything
you got to kind of understand the
situation you're in it so it's important
like everything in IQ don't think that
things are just arbitrary there's not
some arbitrary I I can choose to do this
because it's fun or I think it's
aesthetically pleasing there's a reason
that all the techniques and calm eyes
they exist and so you need to explore
the reasons for those so understanding
why chudan is valuable or what Joe Don's
valuable or like a Don's valuable is
very important if I was facing someone
who is highly skilled and I respected
their skill I would probably try and
stay and cheat on most of the time
because he gives me maximum offense and
defense at the same time if I was
messing with someone who is highly
defensive and they had a good defense
but I felt like their offense wasn't
that good I'd probably go indicate on
because gait on my lure them in not get
an opening that way if I was dealing
with someone who was ferocious I would
probably try to get into Joe Don so that
way I would be threatening them back and
kind of pushing them back so someone had
a really strong offense I would probably
line up in it in a Joe Don but that's
all situational just understand that
each combine has a reason for existing
like everything in Aikido each of the
techniques is not arbitrary
you don't arbitrarily decide to apply an
EQ oh there's a reason that Ethio
happens or Sanko happens or a Joe Don
Kim come on I'm Chris Brian thanks for
watching